friends even not that bad I think we
transatlantic relations officer hit a
low in 2003 the whole cast of characters
apart from Bush himself has now changed
there are different leaders in Britain
France and Germany the italian one has
come back again and i think they're the
will in europe is to make the
transatlantic relationship work and also
i think you know the Putin now Medvedev
factor is making Europeans you know
remember why it's always quite useful to
have the American them to be with the
Americans and not the sense they feel
scared or frightened and like they were
in the cool or days but but it all these
issues a reason to deal with the
Atlantic countries are working together
is the case of a knitted a partisan
point that Europeans have been
absolutely riveted by by the election
campaign and it's for all sorts of
reasons probably rooting for Obama just
because he represented something so
different from from Bush that they can
see the pr advantages at home and we
just not say they will be unhappy with
with Hillary I think they would be fine
with Hillary to that means you because
by a nice day they cover okay with Bill
towards the end I think people forget
just how bad transatlantic relations
were in the first term of Clinton over
Bosnia which was actually very difficult
time and he but by the end he was fine
though Obama represents a different sort
of America and so I think he would have
an unusual opportunity McCain would also
will also have an opportunity because
he's recognized to be a different
abortion and I think would be a concern
that he was carrying on
a blustery sort of foreign policy
whereas I think Europeans would like a
more diplomacy heavy American foreign
policy rather than one that just relies
on sort of the threats and actual use of
force so separate tranexamic relations
aren't really that bad I don't think but
people are waiting you know as indeed
Americans are and I think 2009 will will
be a potentially quite quite an
interesting year in terms of whether you
can see New Directions in western
foreign policy in general